we're continuing to hear from folks in
the audience we do these calls via
Discord you can find the David packman
show Discord at davidpackman.com Discord
for everybody who's waiting to talk to
me remember uh in your nickname you must
have your name and your location so
folks I see with like just a nickname or
a handle or whatever uh you aren't going
to be called on just so you know what
the what the guidelines are for example
we will go to Justin from New Jersey
name and location in that perfect format
I mentioned Justin from New Jersey
welcome what's on your mind
hey David uh it's first time column here
and uh I just wanted to ask you a few
quick questions sure you have a few
questions interesting
uh first of all is do you watch any
anime
I've only ever seen one anime movie it
was like 15 years ago it's called
Spirited Away
I don't think I ever heard of that okay
um
all right um into the political
questions
um
so do you think Rhonda Sanchez is
actually not going to run is that a
possibility I think it's a possibility
but an unlikely one I do believe
DeSantis is going to run it is very
difficult to have a 19 Point win for
governor for re-election to see yourself
polling very well without even having
announced and then to get away from it
because you never know when this
opportunity might present itself again
so I do think DeSantis is ultimately
going to run
because I I think it's interesting
because I can't see a world where Trump
doesn't win honestly I mean listen I
don't just I also think the most likely
scenario is Trump wins the primary
because I really do see him as a very
popular person regardless of it was
DeSantis Nikki Haley or Tim Scott I feel
like the more people actually it just
helps Trump because he has a solid face
compared to these other people that
don't
where I am most
confident that Trump will best DeSantis
is once if and when it becomes a
national campaign with the insults and
the nicknames and the rhetoric
DeSantis is so uncharismatic
and even though they're a republican
insiders that are sick of trump or never
liked Trump I think the imagery of trump
making fun of DeSantis and uncharismatic
DeSantis not really being up to the task
of of punching back I think it's going
to be very tough for DeSantis to win
very tough
I I can agree with that thank you so
much all right Justin from New Jersey
great to hear from you